good evening and welcome to planning
committee Stratford District Council uh
it's the 21st of June my name is
councilor Lewis Adam I'm your chairman
for this evening
uh so I'm going to go through some
housekeeping just to begin with
um there's no planned fire alarm for
this evening so if it does go off please
leave the building in an orderly fashion
the master points the other side of the
road in the car park by the pub please
make sure that all your phones are
turned off or at least turned to silent
just so that we don't disturb the flow
of the meeting
uh this meeting is being recorded and
live streamed on YouTube and the website
um so just be aware of that
now I'll say this just particularly
because obviously the the public Gallery
is very full this evening this is a
meeting in public it is not a public
meeting so only those who are registered
to speak are allowed permitted to do so
they will be called forward at the
appropriate time and given further
instructions at that point
uh right I'm now going to just introduce
the top table
um we got from democratic Services Kira
Keller uh we've got our solicitor Amy
Shipley a planning manager this evening
is Alice cosnet and our planning
planners are Malvina izik uh Stuart
Flaherty and Sarah flirty uh now Alice I
believe you had a statement you want to
say yes thank you chairman my role is to
provide impartial advice and to assist
members in their decision taking
thank you very much lovely all right so
we can now move on to the agenda item
number one is apologies for absence
and councilor Parry with councilor
organist substitute lovely thank you
very much uh item number two is
disclosures of interest I'm just going
to start and say that I've received
Communications from members of the
public on items three and four I believe
other members of the Committees have
received from us so I think we've got
black blanket dispensation there are
there any other disclosures Council
organ
item 2300939
is an item within my ward
come to this meeting with an open mind
and we'll therefore take part in the
deliberation for this item
Abby thank you very much just to clarify
the communications we've received are
actually for items four and five are
there any other disclosures of Interest
no in which case uh we'll move on to
approving the minutes of the previous
meeting held on the 24th of May take it
everyone's had an opportunity to read
the minutes
agreed okay jolly good we'll sign those
in due course in which case we'll move
on to the applications in front of us
now I'm going to move around
um these applications very slightly we
don't have any registered speakers for
item number six which is application
23-00939 slash very greystones 89 shut
Lane elswood as a result we have the
opportunity to delegate to officers
uh would anyone like to propose that we
delegate to officers
yes
there you go there we go
okay I'd like to propose that we
delegate to officers after all that
thank you very much anyone Winton second
councilor Curtis
just happy to second that really good in
that case can I see vote in favor of
delegating to the officers
it's unanimous okay lovely thank you
very much in which case we'll move back
to the first application which is
application 22-03
sorry is this
22-03071 ful
uh Fox and Hounds in Morton and Marsh
Road Great wallford uh there are some
update sheets
um which uh with regards to the title of
the item and our presenting officer
Malvina will run us through that now
take it away
thank you chairman uh good evening so I
would like to draw the attention of the
members to the updates sheet the
counselor received amended plans after
close of business on Monday 19th of June
which have not been accepted in addition
the planning agent withdrew the
application for the listed building
content associated with the full and
therefore only the full application as
originally submitted for two number of
dwellings is being considered tonight
um
as you can see and this is
tonight's agenda and I will move on to
present the application now
the application site is located in a
great Wolford as denoted by the black
dot on this plan
and this is the application site
outlined in red
fox and houtz in is a grade 2 listed
building and in addition the property is
located
within a conservation area as denoted by
the pink outline
the site is also washed over by
cotswold's French special landscape area
designation
the public house is on the asset of
community value list
what is being proposed
um currently planning permission
um is being sold for a change of use of
the public house to two number of
dwellings and Associated development
for which I listed building constant is
also required however the listed
building application was withdrawn
and on this slide you can see the
existing site plan on the left hand side
and the proposed site plan on the right
hand side
on the next slide you can see the
proposed ground floor plan on the left
hand side
and a proposed floor plan first floor
plan on the right hand side you can see
the proposed alterations
in orange color and also denoted by
arrows
this is the proposed second floor plan
and proposed roof plan
on this slide you can see on the left
hand side the proposed front elevation
and on the right hand side you can see
the site elevation
on the next slide you can see
on the left hand side at the rear
elevation as proposed
and on the right hand side the proposed
site elevation
this is the photo of the front elevation
you can see here on the left hand side
the adjacent neighbors this is the
application property there and this is a
adjacent neighbor the Old Coach House
this is a close-up view of the front
elevation
here you can see the rear elevation
and this cable is part of the property
as well as you can see on the next
photograph
and here on the left hand side and the
gray building is is the neighbor or the
Old Coach House
um chairman the recommendation is to
refuse the full application for the
reasons detailed within the committee
report thank you
thank you very much okay we'll move on
to our first Speaker who is Jennifer
green on behalf of walford's joint
Parish Council
good evening
um if you just like take a seat there uh
it's the button on the right to turn on
the microphone you have three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second warning before
we're done and otherwise it's it's
opportunity to take it away
oh you can adjust the height
good evening
who welcomes the recommendation of the
planners that the application is refused
the wolford's claim the permanent loss
of the pub would be detrimental to the
Social and economic well-being of the
community
however we do have concerns that the
planets conclude that the pub will not
be viable in the future
it is important that the committee does
not regard this as a proven fact
which it obviously cannot be exceptions
clearly has implications for any future
applications and also possibly the asset
of community value status that the pub
enjoys
we have addressed our serious concerns
about ever outcall's viability report in
a couple of submissions
they are not considered by the plans
we maintain that none of the criteria
under policy cs25 have been satisfied
at the heart of the report is a
calculation of profitability it starts
with an estimate of turnover the size of
which is essential to the outcome
we were struck by the extremely low
turnover estimate of around 150
000 pounds per annum Which is less than
the average attained 10 years previously
of around 200 000 pounds per annum
we took three methods of estimating
potential turnover
one was by inflating the historic values
the second was taking the professional
assessment in a recent report to
Stratford Council by Addison Young and
the third was to look at very recent
accounts of the community Pub in
Northern Lindsay a village of the same
size as great Wilford
these three estimates are all very close
to one another around two hundred and
forty thousand pounds well in excess of
those of every coal
there are significant errors in every
cold submissions I'll highlight two
examples one is with respect to Northern
Lindsay they claim that it is not a
relevant comparison because its
population is three times that of great
Wilford
the very recent census gives the
population of Norton lindsayers 338
and that of Great Wall for just 307 this
is nowhere near a ratio of three to one
another example is that in their
estimate of turnover they use the price
of a letting room as 70 pounds
web surveys and booking sites given an
average in this area significantly over
a hundred pounds
for a double room with very few below 80
pounds
whether these errors are a result of
gross incompetence or egregious
misdirection I don't know
but it does destroy one's confidence in
their ability to give the balanced
Judgment of future viability okay thank
you very much uh that's your three
minutes honestly requests sorry we'll
reject
thank you very much yeah if you could
stay seated
um and we'll have questions to you from
the members members do we have any
questions for the parish council
councilor Keithley
okay thank you very much for that that
was uh that was very interesting to hear
your presentation
one of the things I'm interested to know
is is
um whether or not this Pub
is the sort of destination Pub and by
that I mean does it rely just on local
people or will it bring people in from
outside to to add to the um to the
turnover and the and the viability the
economic viability of the business
can you help us understand
well it never has been just a local pub
it's always been very popular with
surroundings and I think you can tell
from the
the objections to the current planning
application that they come from a wide
area and this is good evidence that
still people want to come to Great
Wilford to the Fox and Hounds I think
this will be addressed further by the
pump group
thanks very much
councilor Hobby
thank you Council green
um the two reports that have been
considered by put to the committee for
consideration are by
individuals who are both qualifications
and experience in in preparing such
assessments could you elucidate members
of the committee with the experience and
qualifications of the people who
contributed to your evidence please well
it's the parish council
um
I have no qualification in planning but
I do have a lot of experience in picking
up errors and flaws in reports because
I'm a professional scientist and
whenever anything is published
scientifically it's always sent out to
referees and that's the sort of exercise
we've been carrying out on these reports
any other questions counselor passing
yes sorry counselor passing I don't
believe your microphone is turned on oh
hello I'm Sarah yeah yeah not Lindsay is
a community-owned pub if if the pub
became available in great wallford do
you think there's an appetite to for the
community to own this Pub
I think
expect the preference is that it's put
on the market which would be a good way
of assessing whether it's viable
and somebody running it as a the only
way we can see it being a
community-owned pub would be if there
was a compulsory purchase order
councilor Fleming
when these viability reports reports are
commissioned they're usually done by
somebody who wants to prove a point
so they tend not to look at
the viability in a positive sense
they're looking for the viability in a
negative sense
have you got some other figures that you
can put or any any reference or defense
against what they put up because
I think that they have an agenda when
they come with these things do you have
anything to actually fight against that
in terms of real realism we did
important subsequently an objection to
the rebuttal that they sent of our
original objection
um
sorry I've lost lost track
it's um
the thing the thing is that
we are aware that other
local planning authorities have a
slightly more rigorous process than that
which is operated currently by Stratford
Bristol is one example they rely on
um a camera liability
criteria and also they insist that the
pub is marketed for 18 months
before they could consider
change of views
and this is really
um
there's been no recent marketing of this
Pub it was marketed but um
it's claimed that this was just a
planning exercise it wasn't genuine
there were offers well above the current
valuation
so that um
we think that um
respect to this particular
um I have to ask you to wrap up there
all right we just think the ability to
assessment is not valid
thank you any other questions for our
Parish Council no no case counselor
green thank you very much thank you
right we now have a Mr Graham Roberts on
behalf of the save the Fox and Hound
group
hello Mr Roberts
um so yes it's the button on the right
you'll have three minutes I'll give you
a 30 second warning and uh when you're
ready take it away great thank you very
much for giving me the opportunity to
speak on behalf of the campaign group it
also gives me the opportunity to thank
Stratford District Council for both
granting and then later renewing the
asset of community value order that you
have done since you appear to have
accepted the part that the pub plays in
the community and I'm going to focus
mainly upon the financial viability
report and here we do have several
points to make
firstly we say just because this report
has been written by a technical expert
doesn't mean that we or you can't
challenge this report
it's a different if it's a scientific
matter or a highly complex legal matter
but we're not talking about splitting
the atom here we're talking about a pub
and our everyday experience and our
common sense I think can guide us
through and would guide most people
through these arguments
first of all the report leads you to
believe that their lack of a proper
sales process has little importance in
determining the viability of the pub
nothing nothing could be further from
the truth a change of ownership would
bring with a change of management and
this is exactly what most companies do
when they get themselves into trouble
it gives us a chance to reinvigorate our
Pub and in the Pub's case not only do we
change the management we often change
for a new Chef a new face behind the bar
and even a new chance to succeed the Fox
and Hounds deserves the chance to be
reinvigorated
other councils insist upon a proper
sales process taking place for a proper
properly priced Pub being undertaken
before any viability report is
considered Bristol is a good example of
that this should be the best practice
for all councils and we think it should
be your practice as well
the report puts together also a
hypothetical business plan which fails
to recognize that nearly all of our
local pubs
have to be destination pubs a point made
earlier on
and that's attracting custom from
absolutely far and wide
our local pubs can only succeed if they
offer good and interesting food
when you sit down with your friends and
discuss where you're going on a Friday
night you talk about the food that
you're going to be enjoying the
atmosphere there
certainly not the beer and we will get
to it and we and we will love to get to
a village pub that can success we know
that a village pub cannot succeed on wet
sales we we don't think how however that
the author completely understands that
particular point it doesn't recognize
that the remaining point I make is if
you accept this viability report then
you realize these arguments will be
applied to many many pubs across the
Cotswold and you may not just be closing
down the fox and hands you may be
closing down your own pubs thank you for
your time and we trust in your good
judgment thank you thank you very much
members do we have any questions
thank you Mr Roberts again interesting
to listen to you
um you commented that um about the part
that the pub plays in the community
that's how you started
what part exactly is it playing I
understand it's been shut for some quite
some time well I clearly only talk about
the part that it played when it was open
rather than being closed I can talk
about the pop-up pubs later what the pub
has done it gives everybody who moves
into the village an opportunity to meet
new people it's done that very
successfully lots of new friendships
made chances to discuss plans for the
for the village it would be in Years
Gone by the bonfires that we had any
events that we've got it's just a great
social place for people to go to and a
great opportunity in particular for new
people there it's also fair to say that
we also have people in the village that
are single they they know they can go
along to the pub and they know they're
going to be meeting friends and other
people there or even just a phone call
to tell them that
the pub is the heartbeat of lots of
villages and most of all it's the
heartbeat of ours and we can demonstrate
that because the fact that when the pub
did close we've replaced it with a
pop-up Pub you've seen all the pictures
behind the back of you
over the last few years we've raised
well over ten thousand pounds from the
pop-up pubs I have to ask you to keep it
specific to the question being out okay
that's the part of pop-up clubs
like
can I carry on
so so just to clarify then the party
plays in the community is it's a place
for people to come and socialize and
feel part of of great Wilford Community
that's that's the point you're making
absolutely at that point and also other
people from adjacent Villages and Asian
towns as well lots of friendships have
been made at the Fox and Hounds
thank you for that
do you have any other questions
Miss Roberts no
in which case thank you very much
okay we move on to our third speaker now
who is Simon Firkins on behalf of the
applicant
hi Miss Perkins um you have six minutes
uh I'll give you a 30 second warning
it's the button on the right yeah you're
turned on in which case uh start when
you're ready thank you very much
good evening CIA members thank you for
allowing me to speak in support of this
application I have six minutes yes I
hope I will not take anywhere near that
um I've read through the very thorough
report for the change of use of the pub
to residential and know just how much
work officers have put into getting it
to this point
I also know the proposals created
considerable interest and objection Not
Unusual at all when the loss of a pub is
involved
on this point the applicant has provided
offices with all of the information
they've been asked for including the
independent Consultants to assess the
viability report on the council's behalf
pubs are often an important element of
the community and it is right they
receive more protection than some other
uses
at the same time National and specific
local plan policy is clear that the
change of use of a pub is acceptable
where strict criteria are met
as a result of many many reasons outside
the applicant's control the current use
is no longer viable and has not been
viable for some time the The Perfect
Storm of challenges facing the
hospitality industry is well known
it is regrettable but there can be no
doubt that the strict criteria set out
in the local plan have been met here
and there is no policy or other
planning-based reason to resist the
change of use
this is fully set in the report and I
trust you will endorse that as you have
done with other such proposals
with other such proposals that have
rightly provided the same level of
justification
there are no
there are no objections from technical
consulties other than the conservation
officer and it is mainly in connection
with this that there has been some
exchanges of emails with officers in the
last few days
I know you've been told I believe
um that what is before you is the change
of use to two units and there should be
no debate about the change of use to one
I am not seeking to be deliberately
difficult
um or in the slightest disrespectful to
officers or you members
I do they wish to explain why I believe
there is an alternative the LBC
application is withdrawn the description
of development for the fill application
we've asked
we've asked to be altered to change of
use of a house to a single dwelling
and no physical changes to the building
are proposed
plans submitted and received to show how
the building is capable of being used as
a dwelling as it is
instead the suggestion so instead of you
not being able to consider those the
suggestion from offices that we also
withdraw the full application and make a
fresh submission for the use of the
building as a single dwelling which may
benefit from a free go
as the change we've made reduces the
number of units and removes all the
physical changes to the building I don't
believe that reconsultation is essential
there's no statutory requirement to
consult
I can though see why you may wish to do
that
If so reconsulting on the current
application for one dwelling would be
swifter and less costly than dealing
with a fresh one it is well known that
application fees do not anywhere near
cover the cost of receiving registering
validating Consulting on and all the
processing that goes on with an
application the LPA will therefore save
money
by dealing with the current application
as I hope you might more so if the route
advised by officers does benefit from a
free go
the timing of this has not been ideal
and for that I do apologize
I'm not wishing to be difficult on
purpose but the time of recent events
doesn't alter the fact there's nothing I
believe in statute to prevent an
applicant from making changes to their
application at any stage before a
decision is made
officers May well have told you ever
thought otherwise and may continue to do
so I'm here to very respectfully ask you
members to determine this submission on
the basis of the latest information in
your hands
I can very much appreciate why you might
not wish to do that without consultation
having taken place
in the alternative therefore I ask you
to defer this application to allow that
consultation being a more pragmatic and
cost-effective alternative
I thank you for your time and I hope my
suggestions will be received with the
good and helpful intent in which they
are genuinely offered thank you
thank you very much Mr Perkins
members bear in mind the application in
front of us does anyone have any
questions for
Curtis
thank you very much
um looking at the the comments on the
independent report the rod Cole we've
also been told that
it was comparing population of Norton
Lindsay and Wolverton Norton Lindsay
being three times that evolved do you
have any comments on that the accuracy
or I don't know
um the comment I would make is that they
are experts they were employed as
independent Consultants to assess this I
don't believe they have an agenda
and I don't believe there's any
clear evidence out there to dispute the
findings that they've come up with but
on that point I have no comment no
any further questions in that case I
believe you're free to go thank you very
much thank you members
button do I press
the right one yeah yeah that's great
thank you uh in which case move on to
our final speaker who is Ward member
councilor Wally hoggins
good evening councilor
uh you'll know the drill by now
um you'll have five minutes and I'll
give you a 30 second warning otherwise
uh feel free to start when you're ready
this is a two-dwelling application here
we are again yet another Pub in my ward
with an application for change of use
and to develop it for residential
purposes however ladies and gentlemen
this is no ordinary Pub this is the Fox
and Hounds in great Wilford that has
been a destination Pub for both weary
Travelers and the residents of great
Wilford since the 17th century this Pub
has been at the Beating Heart of this
community for centuries and generations
that is until the current very
inexperienced Pub owners took up
residence and slowly but surely stopped
the pub from thriving with erratic
opening hours and ever diminishing bar
stock and a two basic food offering some
might say that theirs has been an
orchestrated and carefully thought out
plan to demonstrate that the pub was
unviable due to a lack of customers the
simple truth is that you cannot have
customers if you do not open the pub or
if you make the out opening hours so
irregular that no one knows when the pub
is open the seemingly orchestrated
decline in the pub has been shameful
this Pub had its doors closed in 2016
when the pub trade was thriving in this
country and particularly in the
Cotswolds a pub cannot be described as
non-viable if it just hasn't been opened
for seven years Covert did not impact
this business because the business had
already been closed for several years
already struck what did impact this
business was the inability of the
applicants to run a successful Pub this
Pub has been closed for seven years and
it has been owned by the applicants for
eight years before that it was a
thriving destination Pub for many all
pubs in my ward are destination pubs
none of them rely on the custom just
from The Villages as the elected
representative of this Ward I am
committed to ensuring that the rural
communities that I represent are
protected using acvs where necessary in
order to ensure that they are places
where people want to live and are able
to thrive I applaud each and every
person and organization have taken the
time and trouble to add an objection to
this application I applaud all those who
have stood out in all weathers at all
times of the year to participate in the
pop-up Pub events demonstrating
unequivocably that the village and The
Wider community support and need a pub I
applaud the people of great Wilford who
have never ceased to regard this Pub as
an asset of community value and have
worked tirelessly to find a way to
reopen this Beating Heart of their
Village and wider Community this Pub has
been listed into an asset of community
value for many years it was a most
recent listing agreed last Autumn this
Pub has been recognized as an ACV really
for generations and has always been of
great importance and significance to
both the current community and
throughout the last three centuries
there is inadequate and flawed evidence
that the pub has no viable future and it
does not demonstrate that any of the
criteria set out under policies CS 25
have been properly considered or
satisfied planning policy cs22 local
employment opportunities must be a prior
especially in areas where there is no
public transport there is no evidence to
support the need for any Residential
Properties of the type in this
application the everard coal report is
fundamentally flawed it is paid for by
the applicant the building itself is one
of the oldest in the village and one of
only a handful that a grade two listed
the pub itself is an iconic feature of
the village whose outskirts are within
the Cotswold protected landscape turn
this Pub into residential use will be an
act of rural vandalism that would never
be repaired unlike the current state of
disrepair this poor neglected building
finds itself in I urge you to refuse
this application so that the fox and
house can once again stand proudly in
serving this Village the wide rural
community and the thousands of visitors
to the Cotswolds once again it is
without doubt a Heritage asset this Pub
has proudly survived two world wars and
countless recessions please ensure that
it survives its current ownership
do to do that it is essential that this
committee refuses this application and
in that refusal you state that you are
not satisfied that the pub is not viable
because clearly this Pub would be viable
under different ownership thank you
foreign
[Applause]
thank you very much
um thank you councilor members do we
have any questions for our Ward member
councilor Curtis first leave
thank you very much councilor
um
I don't suppose you I don't know if
you'll be able to answer this question
but in the report it says that
if you can answer this question a lot it
says in the report that the parking at
Fox and Hounds is a modest size
um
just anecdotally would you say that the
parking is of a reasonable size for a
village pub to allow destination visitor
trade
there's never been
um there's never been a problem with
parking before in the area and I'm aware
that on on peak days there is there is
alternative parking areas available for
that so there is plenty of scope for
adequate parking within within easy
distance of the pub that is that is a
you know
that is a non-statement really thank you
how's the kitty
yeah thank you counselor
um
I enjoyed the standing ovation almost an
innovation for your speech there
um A lot's hanging on the financial
viability of this Pub
and um you've
commented that you feel that the
the non-viability of that Pub has almost
been orchestrated so it can be
demonstrated as it's been run down and I
can kind of get that argument however if
I refer back to the notes I made with
the earlier speaker the income for
Norton Lindsay which had been a
comparable
community-owned pub with
prosperous similar similar size
Community
was 240
000 pounds turnover
and I'm just looking at the
the viability assessment that have been
prepared for the Fox and Hounds on a
hundred and fifty six thousand pounds
turnover if you if you were to take the
gross profit of a hundred and sixty
thousand pounds as a result of the
Norton Lindsay turnover
um and you take some costs off which I
can see
um leaves a remuneration for owners of
just 30 000 so that presumably as a
couple who own it and they're paying 30
000 Grid in wages it leaves what I
described as a fairly modest
profit of twenty thousand pounds
it you know the viability to my mind is
still appears to be marginal even if you
compare it to other pubs in the area of
a similar size that's a keithy can you
come to a question please so so I
suppose my question is
um you say that it's been orchestrated
and you say that the pub would be a
viable Beating Heart of the village but
but I'd put it to you that um pubs of
this sort of size
after the issues of the the hospitality
Traders faced
um are are often quite marginal and I'd
like to hear what you have to say about
a profit of twenty thousand pounds
right then well welcome to the Cotswolds
which is in the furthest Southern point
in my ward alone I am in my ward there
is a substantial number of millionaires
and multi-millionaires what that
actually means is you have got some of
the highest priced houses within within
a very within within five miles of this
Pub one of those houses
um is the most expensive house uh in the
West Midlands what that indicates to you
is that you have got customers who are
going to be coming in they're not just
going to be ordering a pie and a pint
and a pickled egg but they can there
will be champagne on the menus here and
that's what the viability report that
you've taken from everard curl is saying
it's comparing it to an inner city pub
with just people walking past it that is
not the case here when you look at
daylesford people actually go there not
me because I'm from Yorkshire and have
short arms and Deep Pockets uh what what
they do at day is there are people the
same people that live within that
vicinity go there and will spend six
pounds 80 on a loaf of bread that's
their entitlement people have no regard
for that kind of money what they're
looking for is a good destination and I
guarantee that huge amounts of money
will be spent there you you go to bars
and restaurants in in my ward and you
can have a choice of four Champagnes
that that is what the customers are
there for and that is the turnover we
can't talk about the profit here because
the comparisons that have been given
here are just they're just not it is not
an adequate comparison because we
haven't compared it to any of the
offerings that we have
from say any of the other the pubs are
the destination pubs there but the one
of the reasons it's flawed is we are
taking no account of the income bracket
of the people that are living within
this vicinity of this Pub and that's why
we absolutely have to reject this thank
you I know that's a long answer and
thank you for accepting it thank you
thank you I appreciate that um councilor
Fleming next up please
thank you
I live in a rural area
and we've seen pooped close
and it kills villages
it does um my question is that
it's not just about money and I think
that because these reports are
commissioned by people who want the pub
closed you're going to get the figures
that they want exactly so Fleming can
you come to a concise question because
the question is
this Pub can it survive
on the kind of figures that you've just
been talking about but anyway that other
people have talked about you know
sentiment is massive
but practicalities are something else
can this Pub survive
this Pub
this Pub has survived for 300 years it
absolutely can survive because this is
going to be built back better than ever
before and there's a real appetite for
this Pub to be
um serving The Wider community and those
from all income brackets and that is
fundamentally councilor Fleming what's
not been written about here and it's why
I'm asking you at this meeting to reject
that as part of your refusal of this
very quickly please
um I've seen this happened to your
problem brailles I know
um so
and the fact that the owner owned this
for a year before it closed
was it run down on purpose
in your opinion in my opinion okay thank
you
do you have any other questions for our
Ward member
in that case thank you very much
councilor thanks everybody thank you
right we now move on to points of
clarification to our officers
members do we have any points of
clarification for officers councilor
Harvey first a very straightforward
question on the um front page of the
papers the reason for referrals the
committee has given us the discretion of
the head of service do I take it by
implication that this is because it's a
contentious matter or is there some
other reason
yes to confirm it's a contentious item
we're recommending refusal just on the
reason of Heritage and and as you've
seen tonight there is objection on the
basis of Principle as well
the second question
um
just for the sake of clarity and perhaps
my own education
um the asset of community value
compared with listed building status
in planning terms could you evaluate
those compare and contrast so to speak
so I can get that in my head please
I don't think I understand the question
can you for my benefit perhaps other
members of the committee there are two
elements to this at least two elements
to this matter one is that the property
is has been listed as an asset of
community value secondly it is a listed
building and I'm simply asking you as a
planner to tell me as a non-planner uh
how you ex how they relate to one
another do they relate to one another
how I should evaluate them how I should
think about them
understood thank you yeah so they are
two completely separate designations so
assets of community value are designated
under the localism bill whereas listed
buildings are designated under the
conservation enlisted building act I
believe off the top of my head so that
they're two completely separate matters
so
um the fact that the property is listed
as an asset of community value as a
material planning consideration the fact
that it's listed it's also material
planning consideration but obviously
it's much more key in assessing the
application in as much as it needs list
of building consent for any physical
changes to the building so although they
both use the term listed they're very
different ways of being listed
um I have a point of clarification I'd
like to ask as well viability being
um a main point that's been raised I
think all of the speakers uh with
regards to the asset of community value
status was viability a consideration
when determining that
[Music]
bill it does require that a property is
shown to be viable before it can be
listed as an asset of community value
thank you very much are there any other
points of clarification to the officers
Ley thank you thank you chair
um
when I looked to the photographs I could
see that the neighbors were quite close
to this Pub is that is that right did I
see that that the the neighbors are very
close the Coach House and the adjoining
building
uh yes correct
um can you tell me whether or not there
were any have there been any neighbor
amenity complaints
um while while the um you know as a
result of this property being run as a
pub because it's so close to the these
neighbors
um I do not recall any complaints about
proposals resulting in
unacceptable impacts on the residential
amenity no okay thank you
counselor Harvey
um can I just ask the officer to confirm
something
that's and Council hoggins raised I
think I heard her say that the the
applicant paid for the Edward Cole
report
is that the case well first of all I
presume that's I heard it correctly if I
didn't I'll withdraw the question but
assuming that I did is that correct
yes I can confirm that that is the case
and and that is standard practice I
believe across other Council as well and
the reason for that it's it's set out on
our local list which is published on our
website in respect of viability
assessments and it states that when the
council needs its own independent advice
on your viability assessment this will
be paid for by the applicant now the
justification for that is it remains
independent we require the consultant to
confirm that there's no conflict of
interest that they are providing an
independent view on the viability
appraisal the reason the applicant is
required to pay is because they're the
ones who are justifying a conflict of
policy obviously in this case we want to
protect pubs that's what cs25 of the
core strategy expects so the onus is on
the applicant to demonstrate why that's
okay so because of that this
justification and requiring that the
applicant pays for that but like I say
the instruction comes from the council
the council
um ensures that there is not that
conflict of interest and so to my mind
despite some of the comments which have
been made tonight that everard coal
report is an independent report despite
the applicants paying for it that's very
common practice and like I say set out
on our local list
so just for clarification
um you're confirming that the client
that commissioned the report and to whom
the report was made is the council
any other points of clarification
in which case we can move on to the
debate would anyone like to start
councilor Eden
thank you chair
um
obviously a lot of passion in the room
today about something that's desperately
important
to the Village itself
despite the applicants
um
speech we are only here to determine
this application not the one bedroom
that's the alternative
and to my mind it's easily laid out why
that's causing harm
and the withdrawal of the LBC itself for
me
unhinges that argument even more and on
that basis I would propose that we go
with the officer's recommendation and
refuse
thank you very much councilor Eden I saw
counselor Curtis first
thank you
um
notwithstanding the
um Independence
of the viability assessment I do have a
few
concerns over some of the conclusions if
you like
um page 10
it says the pub would not be able to
rely solely on local resident custom
I shouldn't think there are any Village
pubs that rely solely on local custom
ly my local doesn't and it has a huge
car park
um I'm also surprised by the comment the
report states that the food food-led
business brings lower profit margins
councilor Eden may have a better
knowledge of that but my understanding
as a layperson I accept is that is that
it's food that brings in much greater
profit margins which is why we see such
a proliferation of gourmet pubs fuzzy
duck and and so forth
um my third query is over the turnover
assessment now
we heard a comparison of Norton Lindsay
um the comparison with Norton Lindsay
was that Norton Lindsay has three times
the population and this seemed to be how
the potential turnover was calculated
but looking at these figures if the
potential turnover was well if the
turnover 10 years ago was 200 000
Brandon
it doesn't seem unreasonable to think
that with good management
um the turnover could be in the region
of 240 000 as in Norton Lindsay and that
would turn this deficit of 33 000 into a
very healthy margin so
I although this report may be
independent
um I I think we can still challenge some
of the assumptions made therein thank
you
thank you I'd also be happy to Second
counselor Eden's proposal thank you very
much councilor Harvey
um
as a as a ward member for for tradington
I live in the village of armscott
armscott lost pub the Fox and Goose and
it was closed for a number of years
before it was rescued rebranded
redeveloped
and it was literally rebuilt effectively
from top to bottom new roof new drains
and everything in between was was
renewed
and that was financed by a woman who had
a particular reason for doing that and
that was because she wanted to use that
particular purpose of showcase for rooms
so they were a very particular
circumstances but I I mentioned that
simply because I know personally what it
is like to live in a village where the
pub has shut it's not good
in this particular instance
we've got two reports
from people who are experienced by
professional qualification and by years
of experience of actually doing the job
they both come to the same conclusion
you can argue
at the edge about the figures and you
can question certain assumptions and and
that's fine
but you've got two professionals who are
asked to do a job they both did the job
one independently and they both came to
the same conclusion my own small piece
of evidence is that one of the
uh pubs to which reference is made as a
as a lighthouse so to speak is uh is in
tradington in my ward which did reopen
after six years
um and it is currently doing pretty well
uh its turnover is currently at the rate
of roughly uh half a million a year
the difference between that and the Fox
and Hounds is that rather than having 20
covers the particular Pub I'm talking
about has 80 covers it's four times the
size
and that calls me into calls into
question the size of the small the
smallness of of the the the Fox and
Hounds
um I think you have to be sat here
listening to evidence applying evidence
in relation to policy you have to be
pretty cynical to dismiss two
professional evaluations in the face of
alternate assessments which come from
individuals who don't claim any
experience in the hospitality field and
who don't claim any experience in in
accountancy
so I am inclined on the basis of
the the questions of viability to accept
uh that the that it is on viable and
therefore there is Good Grounds to say
that uh cf-25 is satisfied however we
have a conservation officer and the
conservation officer's view is quite uh
quite clear that there would be less
than substantial harm caused by this
particular application and on the base
of this particular application on the
grounds of the conservation officers
recommendation and Views I'm prepared to
refuse this application
thank you very much councilor Harvey
um I'd like to speak as well on this
item um
I think actually Council Harvey touched
on something that I've been feeling into
we are looking at professional reports
that we have to consider with that
context on that basis I don't feel that
we can go against cs25 on the basis but
they are professional reports on this
that the evidence base we have that
being said uh that I have been moved by
the the speakers that we've heard
and I was
considering the impact that viability
has in terms of not just Financial
viability as it's stated under cs25
but also viability on a more macro scale
as which I.E interpret differently
for cs22
now
cs22
as is included in the report
um
it states an existing employment site
should not be redeveloped or converted
to non-employment uses unless it is no
longer viable or appropriate for a
business purpose
that doesn't necessarily mention
Financial viability now I think of
viability in that case as being a
different way of conceptualizing it
we're talking about whether pubs are
still viable within the society that we
live in
not whether this particular one can turn
a profit within the certain time period
one of the questions of clarification I
asked was whether it was uh whether
viability was material in its assessment
to be a asset of community value the
answer was yes that suggests to me that
following its closure in 2016 it was
found viable which means that viability
fluctuates over time planning
permissions exist in perpetuity
I would suggest then
the viability Financial viability we
have to accept
is not being found at this state but the
viability under cs22 can be considered
because we know the pubs of this scale
can and do exist in neighboring Villages
of similar position on that basis I
would
get some advice from our officers as to
whether the basis of principle under
cs22 can also be considered along with
the Heritage aspects
the being used in the ground's full
refusal
at which point I'm going to talk to
Alice
thank you chairman
um yeah so as
agenda packs cs22 requires that an
existing employment site should not be
redeveloped or converted to
non-employment uses unless it is no
longer viable or appropriate for
business purpose a rigorous assessment
of each proposal of this nature will be
undertaken so officers have obviously
had regard to that and we consider that
the viability report which has been
submitted by the applicant and
independently assessed by everard Cole
on behalf of the council is sufficient
to
um comply or show compliance with with
that part of cs22 which is why we have
been satisfied to recommend approval
however members can obviously balance
things very differently
um like you say
pubs are a bit of an interesting one and
if members were to say that despite the
contents of the viability reports you
don't think it has been sufficiently
demonstrated that an operator could turn
a profit on this this Pub then you you
know that's within the gift of a viewers
decision makers I will caveat that by
saying that that these two viability
reports which have been undertaken are
the most up-to-date information we have
on viability so yes
a viability assessment was obviously
undertaken in respect of the asset
Community value listing that's older
than this one
so that's why as officers we give that
more weight the one which says that it's
not viable but similarly I take the
point and uh can't argue with the point
the councilor Adam makes that viability
is inevitably going to fluctuate and
it's unpredictable so now I can say it's
within the gift of a viewer's committee
to to weigh things differently to how
officers have
thank you very much less comprehensive
uh on that basis councilor Eden could I
propose
a friendly amendment to include cs22 as
a part of your
please go on
one extra thing I would just like to add
um is obviously because we have the
viability reports as the most up-to-date
evidence base which say it's not viable
there would be a risk of costs appeal if
we were to refuse on principle so I just
have to make members aware of that that
isn't a tool to say you're not entitled
to do that just putting that out there
thank you thank you very much
um I I do appreciate that and we do have
to be very aware of the potential costs
I personally think that given the
significant community in Impact that's
been demonstrated it is in this case
worth that risk that is my personal View
on that basis I would suggest that we
include that as a matter of principle
for the reasons for refusal
that is what I'm proposing to councilor
Eden
feel free to comment
I'm not 100 comfortable with that chair
I'll be honest
um I think we've got sound enough reason
to go as a refusal anyway
I think
um
it might give I understand your your
purpose behind that and uh and your
Direction behind that
but I think that might give a further
hook further down the line for somebody
to get hold of
actually counter so
I'm happy with this propos with with it
as it stands on this application that
we've got sufficient grains so I'm going
to reject your friendly Amendment I'm
afraid fair enough would anyone else
like to speak in the debate
pastor pattingham
yeah I I think it's important to protect
Community assets like pubs I remember
the fox and hands when it was a really
thriving Pub it was a very popular
destination and I'm looking forward to
seeing that again
and there's obviously a lot of community
support for it which I think is very
important so um I'm I'm in favor of
rejecting the application
thank you uh councilor Curtis thank you
Joe can I just ask for again for a bit
of clarification
um
counselor Eden are you suggesting or is
it suggested that if we also use policy
cs22
there's a grounds for refusal that is
more likely to leave us open to
challenge
my
um professional opinion is yes
so can I ask the chair then um
even with that bearing that in mind
do you would you as chair feel that
also using policy cs22 to refuse
would give greater
assurance
that the pub could be retained as a
Community Asset and look to be returned
for use as a pub in the future
yeah so the the reason I was looking to
include cs22
was because I understand that when
appeal considers items that it looks at
the basis of principle
and the Heritage aspects would in my
view stand up in the way that the
officers are proposing which is clearly
supported by a number of members I don't
feel that the appeal would be
majorly at risk because of those
being
remaining items I was hoping to
strengthen that to maintain
another principle of opposing it being
converted that was the reason for it
in which case I would be happy to
propose refusal on taking into account
both policy cs22 and cs25
if Council Adam would be happy to
okay so that appears to be a new
proposal which would be a change to the
which would mean you'd have to withdraw
your seconding to counselor Eden
and make that proposal as well thank you
very much
I believe I saw councilor organ next
it is I see no reason to differ from the
officer's recommendations on this item
thank you very much and I believe
councilor Keith Lee wanted to speak next
yeah thank you chairman
um I I've just been reflecting on what
you said
um about uh cs22
um clearly well in my mind certainly
there are very many questions about the
viability of the financial viability of
this asset and business
and it's a very difficult balance to get
between viability and Community benefit
however
looking at cs22 and reading what you've
read a minute ago it does say that that
um
you know uh an existing employment site
should not be redeveloped or converted
to non-employment use unless it's no
longer viable or appropriate for a
business purpose
and and my view on this is although
there have been independent reports on
the viability I'm not persuaded that
they are
totally
accurate things changed
um you know when you're marketing
um business opportunities some people
come up with really innovative ways of
of making something work
so I I would on that basis
um I'm not I'm not persuaded that it's
financially unviable necessarily and I
think that it could
potentially have a future business
purpose and for that reason I'd like to
Second counselor Curtis's proposal
to include policy cs22 as well as the
the Heritage reason
thank you very much councilor Keithley
all right bear with me two seconds
right thank you very much everybody
would anyone else like to speak in the
debate
no okay so just for clarity we now have
two proposals both are to refuse the
application
the first made by councilor Eden is to
refuse the application in line with
officers recommendations which is
primarily and solely on heritage
specs the second is
counselor Curtis's proposal to refuse
in line with the officer's
recommendations with the addition of
cs22 being added to that reason
right because Council Adams was seconded
first that's the one we'll have to hear
first so
on that basis
I want to make sure I get this exactly
right
The Proposal is to refuse the
application in line with officers
recommendations
kind of see all those in favor
that is six
and all those opposed
three
in which case
that passes and the application is
refused
for clarity
this Council this committee resolves to
refuse application
22-03071 ful in line with the officer's
recommendations
okay thank you very much
members I'm just going to take a sort of
temporary adjournment just to let the uh
let the public clear and then we'll
commence with the next item thank you
very much
foreign
all right everybody we're going to move
on to our next item now which is item
number five which is application 18 0 1
2 5 3 very uh which is the Airfield at
Smithfield Road beardley
stratford-on-avon
um I'm gonna add a note at this point
that
um one of our officers from
environmental health Ben Ellis is on the
call for points of clarification uh
later on otherwise our presenting
officer is Stuart take it away
foreign
thank you chairman good evening
this proposal is seeking the removal of
a condition on planning permission
reference
1001059 fairy which limited the use of
touring motorized gliders to a period of
three years at Stratford and Avon
gliding Club this proposal thereby seeks
permission to enable the permanent use
of touring motorized gliders tmgs
the application site is in between the
settlements of beerley and sitterfield
as shown on this by the black dot on
this plan the application site is washed
over by the green belt in addition to
being in a designated special landscape
area
here we see the redline application
boundary for the site the dotted pink
line to the left here denotes the ward
boundary and the parish boundary as well
uh Billy is located to the west of this
line inclusive of this little segment
here in the site the majority of the red
line area as you can see within the ward
and Parish of sniterfield
here we have a satellite image of the
application site and its wider
surroundings one can note the uh open
Countryside nature of it with both
schnitterfield bushes here and barely
bushes here as as designated Woodland in
addition to further Woodland known as
Hawks wood in proximity here
we now have some photos of the site and
its surroundings uh here we are stood
next to the clubhouse looking South
Eastward uh one can see a winch
hopefully if you if it's not too small
uh where my cursor is there and one can
see Woodland in The Wider background
um here we see I stood on the Northern
edge of the site looking South westwards
uh here one can see what is a
non-motorized glider in situ on the
Airfield site planning permission was
previously granted in 2015 with a
conditioner posed for the use of tmgs
for a temporary period of three years
this was imposed to ascertain the impact
of these specific gliders on the amenity
of the area owing in part to the
submission of a technical noise impact
assessment by the applicant that has
been assessed by officers the local
planning Authority has seen nothing
since granting the permission 2015
suggests that these tngs cannot be made
permanent partly for methods of
consistency and in continued interests
of safeguarding amenity previously
imposed conditions such as the limits on
the timings and number of powered
takeoffs are suggested by officers to be
imposed were members minded to Grant
planning permission Stratford and Avon
gliding Club is acknowledged in both the
barely and Centerfield naked development
plans as being a Leisure and Sport
facility for both the local and wider
Community it is understood that the club
has been based here at this site for
over 34 years having considered all
material planning considerations
inclusive of massive noise impacts
impact in The Wider area and more The
Proposal is found by officers to Accord
with local and National policy
um I refer you all to to some items on
the update sheet for further details uh
chairman the recommendation is to Grant
Subject to Legal agreement for the
reason set out on pages 35 and 36 of
your agendas thank you
thank you very much
um now we would at this point move on to
our first Speaker who is going to be the
chairman of Bailey Parish Council but I
understand is not present in which case
we move on to our next speaker who's Mr
Andy balkwin on behalf of the applicant
hello Mr spoken you have three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second warning and
start when you're ready
just for the record it's bulk will
so
um yes my name is Andy balkwell I'm the
chairman of Stratford on Avon gliding
club I'm qualified flying instructor in
both gliders and motor gliders I've been
flying at sneterfield for 25 years
the club was formed in 1974 and moved to
snitterfield in 1987. we are a community
amateur sports club a cask
and we are run entirely by volunteers
our aim is to make gliding as widely
accessible as possible
gliding offers an affordable opportunity
to learn to fly because it's around one
quarter of the cost of powered flying
that you might undertake somewhere like
wellsborne
many of our junior members aspire to
careers in aviation and gliding
represents their first step along that
path
as a result we have a wide range of
members in terms of age background and
all walks of life
to obtain a glider pilot's license it is
now necessary under UK regulations for
students to complete their training in a
motor glider
these new regulations have been
introduced well it started in about 19
2010 and the transition is now well
underway and will compete in complete in
the motor glider allows us to undertake
exercises such as navigation and
simulated field Landings that would
otherwise be completely impractical in a
glider as a result this improves both
pilot safety and and improves their
training
we're a gliding club we don't want to
operate light aircraft we don't want to
operate microlights we don't want to
operate helicopters our application is
just limited to motor gliders and
approval of the application will allow
us to continue to train glider Pilots
the planning permission to allow the
motor glider was first approved in 2013
although subsequently overturned in 2014
it was then granted on a temporary basis
as
Mr flattery has already said in 2015 and
the reason for the temporary permission
was to give the council time to assess
the impact
of our operations and our compliance
with the conditions
since then we've undertaken
um some 1060 flights with the motor
glider
okay
um and um
we've only had one problem which when
brought to our attention was immediately
corrected so in conclusion I'd just like
to say we have an established track
record of meeting the conditions and
therefore we would like to invite the
council to approve the permission so
that we continue continue to run the
training into the future with some
certainty thank you
bang on time thank you very much members
do we have any uh questions for our
applicant uh yes sir counselor Harvey
good evening
how would you describe your
relationships between your club and
local residents organizations bodies
um
with barely not great
[Music]
um
it's interesting I used to work so the
Billy Parish Council chairman Dr aromatz
I worked for him about two or 25 years
ago
um we do not see eye to eye on the
gliding Club
but we've never had any issues as far as
I'm aware with slitterfield or with
wilcoat
can I use the word cordial two to one
sorry can I use the word cordial two to
one
cordial yes
thank you very much um councilor Kurt is
next
thank you chair
um
others made it could you just explain
briefly the difference between a powered
glider and a glider
so a motor glider touring motor glider
is a particular category of aircraft
it's
um
it has a fixed engine it looks in many
ways similar to a light aircraft it's
it's got
conventional wings but they're long like
a glider the idea is you take off
underpower and then you can turn the
engine off or turn it down and simulate
the behavior of a glider and undertake
gliding
exercises in it
um
yeah I'm not sure I can add much more
councilor Fleming
um I live quite close to Big Marsh
gliding club and they're using powered
planes to take
so you don't have any towed aircraft to
get in the air at all then you said
there's no light aircraft are these just
purely winched up or are they powered up
by themselves their winch so the gliders
on the sides are winched you saw a
picture earlier on of the winch that's
been operating since 1987 and well not
that precise winch but we have had
winches on site since 1987. we do not
have
um aeroto and we don't have permission
for that and we would not seek
permission for that because I don't
think our field is suitable and from
what little I understand of the planning
framework that's something that would we
would never get so we are purely a winch
site but we do need use of the motor
glider to cover some aspects of training
I'm guessing that these powered gliders
only have small engines they're not
particularly noisy can you confirm that
so that the
the motor glider has a it's a an in I
think it's a VW Beetle derivative engine
it's an air-cooled engine it's
it's very quiet
um
the other types of glider I think you're
referring to are the self
self-sustaining gliders that their
engines are tucked away inside they're
launched on the wire in a completely
conventional sense
the engine only gets used basically when
you know if the glider is 50 or 100
miles away from the Airfield and it runs
into an area where there's no lift and
it's struggling to stay in the air
um you can
erect the engine start it and it will
then get you to an area
um where there's better lift or even get
you back to site
they are not particularly quiet but on
the other hand
um you know they're not being used
within the vicinity of the Airfield we
have an established two nautical mile
Zone around the Airfield you in within
which we do not use the engines on the
self-sustainers
and we have as I'm sure you've probably
aware we also have a number of noise
abatement zones over the local Villages
of beerley snita field
and uh wilmcoat over which we will not
fly the motor glider
and and you're going to come with these
extra
um
gliders you're still going to comply
with all the noise abatement notices
around and whatever else you're not
looking for any variation to those
correct and and the noise study that we
had undertaken that was recently
consulted on I think confirmed that
thank you Roger um any other questions
for applicant
no in which case uh thank you very much
thank you and apologies for the name Rob
uh okay we'll now move on to our last
speaker who is our Ward member uh
councilor Parker
good evening councilor
so you've got five minutes I'll give you
a 30 second warning
um and feel free to start when you're
ready can I just say a couple of words
before before I start which is just the
parish councilor from Bailey
unfortunately couldn't be here tonight
obviously he would like to be here but
his wife has medical conditions which
doesn't allow him and I would be
grateful if someone would read out his
statement in his absence at some stage
as you're about to hear I'm pretty
dyslexic so I'm not going to be the one
to read it out because it won't come out
as some smooth bit of oratory it will
come out like Chitty Chitty Bang Bang
okay so in 2015 permission was granted
uh for three years and this was a trial
has already been described uh for
touring motor gliders at the club
uh the very uh in this application uh in
front of us is to remove condition one
uh and in doing so makes all other
conditions that are given in that list
permanent
so the trial has shown that with the
associated limits on flights that the
tmgs are broadly tolerable
uh condition 20 which would of course
become permanent uh with this uh should
this pass
changes uh the sound emissions from the
previous 1987 values and so that would
then be permanent Shrine should this
pass
condition 20 does not Safeguard the
immunity from winch noise which impacts
residents and in fact
um what I would like folks to focus on
is not uh the the tmgs but the fact that
the amount of sound emissions uh has
changed with this application
effectively
it is requested uh that there is a
deference of this to allow a full study
of the impact of the winch noise on
um members in barely which as you heard
previously the relationship is is not
quite as we would all like it and we
would like more time to
to to get some more data on on the sound
characterization and to build some
bridges
um
and obviously a deferment is not wholly
impactful to the gliding Club because
they could keep flying their tmgs in the
meanwhile
uh alternatively should folks uh uh not
feel so minded to go that way an
alternative although perhaps less
satisfactory uh would be to augment
condition 20.
such that no single winch event should
exceed the original 50 decibels DBA that
is at the Airfield boundary so this is
the superseded value
in this application and and so what I'm
setting forward is perhaps uh a means of
um bringing this to a
a conclusion might be to add that as a
condition of approval
any questions
thank you thank you very much councilor
Parker
um members do we have any questions for
our award member
councilor homes first I believe
so
you're requesting that there'd be more
time to assess the sound the the issue
of excess noise but why hasn't that been
done before or what what what would you
have liked to have done and why couldn't
that have been completed before
so so forgive me first first of all I
I'm I'm not long in the job I haven't
got my feet right under the table
um uh and and I think that that is a a
sane question and I think the issue uh
is around
um when one reads the the pack of course
uh
and all the discussion hitherto on this
has all have been about all been about
the tmgs
um and uh and that's an important
discussion uh but I think for uh the the
people of uh Bailey and snitterfield
um you know that isn't the the primary
issue and and so uh hitherto
um the the work required uh to
um understand winch noise has not been
the focus of the activity uh and uh and
I say again uh that of course by uh
moving to this uh by but by making uh
condition one permanent we are then
making condition 20 permanent
thank you
very much Council Keith next
um well it's really a follow-up to to
the previous question in a way but what
I'm struggling to understand is um
is this issue of the 50 DBA at the
Airfield boundary can you tell me
whether or not there have been any
complaints about the winch noise
registered with the local Authority
uh I I I believe that winch noise has
been going on has been ongoing issue for
many many years
and others I'm sure who have been uh in
this circus longer than myself would
know more
okay thanks that doesn't answer my
question but um it's been going on but I
asked if there'd been any complaints so
okay thanks very much councilor sorry
there have been complaints
I beg your pardon
any other questions for our award member
uh no I don't think so
um I've got the the statement from the
parish counselor um
I'm reviewing it with what you've said
obstensively you've said the same things
that was raised in that uh despite some
the names of British standards so I'm
satisfied that they've you know imparted
that through yourself so thank you for
your consideration okay no worries thank
you very much
okay
um we're now moving on to
points of clarification for our officer
uh bearing in mind that we have
um
Mr Ben Ellis from environmental health
um that might be uh somebody who can
address some of the queries that were
raised um first I'm going to go to
counselor Harvey
thank you chairman it is a question for
Mr Ellis
um has Mr Ellis heard anything this
evening
which would provoke him into requesting
more time for a deferral or in the need
of more information or would he
would he uphold his current view that he
has no objection
um thank you councilor um no I think the
winch noise in particular has been
adequately assessed and uh there's
there's nothing that's been raised
um
in the responses there that would change
my opinion at the moment
any other points of clarification
Curtis
again another question for the
environment officer if I could please
um is there any evidence
that allowing the power gliders will
increase winch noise
no the the winch as I understand it and
it may be a point to clarify with the uh
with the the owners but the the winch is
used on all of the gliders so there
shouldn't be any difference in that the
study shows that there's no difference
in the winter noise with the with the
power gliders or the unpowered gliders
it's the same winch
okay chair would we be able to clarify
that with the owners that that would be
the case or not
seconds
as this is a disputed fact
um I'm able to
insert my discretion to call back the
the applicant just to to comment on that
but I would stress that it has to be a
very
brief and technical response
thank you
so the gliders the powered gliders that
are launched on the winch are no
different externally to an unpowered
glider they look identical
and there's no difference to the amount
of noise caused during the winch launch
technology is obviously separate thank
you very much
are there any other points of
clarification to our office uh Council
passing them can I ask Ben Alice
um has any assessment been done of the
noise of the motors then the air called
VW engines I I think I heard which I I
remember as being quite noisy but
um yes the um the noise assessments that
have been undertaken taken into
consideration the noise of the
um
the motor glidering motor glider and a
number of winch launches within an hour
period
and and
what was the result of the assessment
so the uh assessment shows that it can
comply with the limits that were set
back in uh 2015 and that they are also
below
um the
um sort of government standard for
lowest observed effect level which is 51
decibels so that it's the limit is the
on the site the bespoke limit is 45
decibels over an hour so that's
more restrictive than the national
guidance quite considerably more
restrictive than a national National
guidance and the report shows that it
can comply with that
thank you very much are there any other
points of clarification
in which case we can move on to our
debate who'd like to start
counselor Curtis I'll kick us off chair
um
I just think we it's just a sort of
comment really that we need the
application before us
is to allow
or to continue the use or the flight of
these powered gliders as I understand
we're not looking at
the noise coming from the winch
so I think we just need to be clear what
what the application is that's actually
before us
thank you counselor um primarily yes the
application before you receiving is a
proposed removal of condition one of the
previous position to to remove the
temporary nature of it
um but as has been I think touched upon
by by Ben and certainly as his room as
is included in the noise impact
assessment review that that has
considered all matters inclusive of the
TMG and the winch
um in combination uh with each other the
noise impacts in its entirety thereof
um we're not uh we are including impacts
of the noise of the winch in this
assessment for you this evening
councilor Harvey
uh I think this is a straightforward
matter
that there are
the officer is clear in his
recommendation
there are no objections from the long
list of consultees
um
the environmental health officer
and has answered all our questions he is
satisfied I can find no objections no
ground for objections no no hint of
hesitation in the officer's report
and therefore I am more than happy to
propose this application be granted
councilor homes next
um thanks very much so we've had a
proposal from councilor Harvey and has
been secreted by councilor homes
somebody else anyone else want to speak
sorry no
cost passing him
uh
I can't see any grounds for rejecting it
on planning grounds but I still think
it's very important to keep noise levels
low in the in the countryside and know
how annoying it is to me and to most
people so I'm really minded to abstain
thank you councilor
um so yeah I think would you want to say
something councilor Keithley I don't
know that I mind you just support the um
proposal and the second despite the fact
that I read There were objections from
Parish councils what we've heard is that
the compliance for the national guidance
on noise is met comfortably
thank you yes I think I'd um agree with
that and and what's previously been said
to that effect
um on that basis we have a proposal on a
second do Grant in line with officers
recommendations can I see all those in
favor
that's eight
all those opposed
and abstentions
one in which case this committee
resolves to Grant application
1801253 slash Berry
and
subject to a section 106 agreement
thank you very much
okay so the last item on the agenda is
item number seven urgent business
no urgent business in which case I'll
close the meeting thank you very much